you know different people make different
choices for their bodies
we had a call that came in right here
let's hear it
hey theo how you doing man my name is
jesse
um i was a united states inheritor
i was a mariner for about five years i
just recently got out man uh
calling in for some advice my dad called
me the other day
he owns a strain of motels over there in
flint michigan
he's been in the hotel business my whole
life
and um oh yeah over there in flint baby
those dirty water motels
you know those brackish little bed shops
baby onward
he was telling me he wants to get a low
back tattoo and
dude i'm gonna tell you man you can't
you can do what you want but you also
can't get a low back tattoo if you were
man
okay this ain't the future
this is right now
and i that right there is a gateway drug
to homosexuality and probably prison
time
and it's fine if that's what if those
are the things you're looking for
but if you're just looking to do a
little snazzy body art
you don't get a back a lower back tattoo
especially if you slang in hotel rooms
man
you gonna have a couple fellas trying to
sleep up in your ass brother onward
being a straight single man i told him i
wouldn't recommend getting anything
tattooed on
on your lower back as a straight man but
um
you know he's my dad i want to respect
him i want to hear him out and he said
well son i want to get the hotel logo
tattooed on my low back
well look man you know what actually bro
get it
i say you get dude get two flames coming
off the side coming right around to his
hips
the end of the flame just ending right
down towards his nuts
get that get a big huge banana right up
and down his spine man
and get the hotel or whatever it is
ramada you know
jerry's tight stay right there above his
ass get that
do him right treat your daddy right what
am i talking why am i saying
no when i should be saying yes
lean into the fun that's why
too much i'm i'm i'm telling say don't
do don't
lean into the fun take a chance
rent your daddy a nice brother with that
big body hammer for tonight
you know big uh big stanley big stanley
the stallion
you know what i'm saying get your get
your daddy dick down properly
out there let him live his life
i'm sorry i said no
i am sorry that i said no brother go on
and get it
and i hope your dad does it all i hope
he does it damn
all dude and i hope he probably does
oral you know live a little
pc baby praise christ good evening good
afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you could watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could
watch this one or watch this one watch
this one watch this one
watch this one ah